so the names ed came about because my
last name starts with a Z and I grew up
in Germany and in Germany it's not a Z
it's a Zed the whole electronic music
project for me was just a hobby
I didn't even release my first album I
just gave it to my friends to listen to
and just so they know what it is we're
like we'll just call it dead it's fine I
don't care it's not that important
what's up GQ my name is Zed
I travel a lot so I have a lot of
essentials and here they are I don't
actually know exactly what the model is
I know they're adidas but the most
important thing is the soul and that
they're very comfortable I jump on stage
for 90 to 120 minutes a day and wearing
uncomfortable shoes is really bad I like
the look of them most of the times
people can't really see it because my
feet are covered anyway but it's a nice
bonus when one day it look nice I have
way too many pairs of sneakers so I
bought a house and it has two closets I
have my closet for my clothes and I
turned the other one to a shoe closet
I decided for myself then as soon as
it's completely full I'm gonna I'm still
gonna get more shoes but I'm gonna
replace them and then I'm gonna give the
Devon said I replace away a portable
battery I don't know why I'm so obsessed
with these because obviously I could
just regularly charge my phone
but I think sometimes on the plane you
don't have another way of charging a
phone I just like the thought that I'm
covered if I need it
I sometimes get into trouble because I
guess these things are considered
dangerous when you fly and they will
look at like oh how much how much 20,000
all okay is that all you have is like no
I got five more at some point had like
eight and I remember we were in China
and you're only allowed to carry a
certain amount so it was literally a
matter of you can take two I'll take
this one you take that one splitting it
between my entire team my next essential
is sweatpants with zippers the zipper is
the crucial part for me I fly in
sweatpants every single day I can't wear
jeans on the plane
and I have nightmares of waking up in my
phone not being in my pocket so I got
these sweatpants that are super comfy
but they didn't have a zipper so I added
a zipper so now I can use them on the
plane it's quick and easy and it will
save you from waking up on the plane in
panic mode
my next essential sunglasses I feel like
that's an essential for almost everybody
in the world I always wear the same pair
of sunglasses and I also don't lose them
these ones I believe these are the
Erica's gives me a little bit of throw
bag lives I don't know what we're
throwing back to but I like them they're
simple they're super light they look
good on anyone by the way black
sunglasses just always work they're
never out of place no matter what you
wear put them on and it works the phone
is kind of obvious
I think that's an essential for
everybody nowadays the wallet stick or
whatever you want to call it on the back
of my phone I think like three or four
years ago someone from my team got this
and put in their you know credit card
and ID and stopped carrying a wallet and
to me I have always had a huge wallet
with a million cards cash different
currencies anything you can imagine and
I decided to just give it a try
so I figured what is the really most
important thing that I actually use
every day it's my credit card and
alternative credit card for when people
don't take em X my driver's license and
my hotel key so those are honestly the
only four things I ever need and I don't
have the world and I haven't had a
wallet in probably four years now I've
never been in a situation where I'm like
I wish I had my wallet because I don't
need it another essential for me are
earplugs these are customized earplugs
by HTS I mean I'm on stage or living so
I need to detect my ears these earplugs
that have a little hole in the back you
can exchange the filter for example you
go to some place a bar and it's a little
bit loud you can put a 6 DB filter in so
it's just gonna make it a little bit
quieter you go to a really loud concert
you can put in other filters that are
gonna make it much quieter a lot of
people don't want to wear earplugs
because it kind of makes the sound worse
at a show its muffled it kills all the
highs these don't these just keep the
exact same sound it is and just makes it
quieter because you can't feel them
they're custom-made for your ear so they
basically put wax
kind of thing in your ear or nowadays is
to do a 3d laser scan of your ear and
then they print them out have earplugs
protect your ears very important you're
not gonna get them back
my next essential is maybe boring for
most people but really essential for me
these two keys
this is my life this is my license keys
to the software I used to produce music
which is Cubase and then this key for
all my plugins all the sounds I use
they're all on this key and thanks to
Apple for removing my use B's I need to
put these in here and then Thank You
Apple I can't put this in my new macbook
anymore because they took them from me
so I need a adapter and then I can put
that into my laptop yeah Apple when you
have a lot of essentials in your life
you need a place to put them for me it's
a Tumi backpack it's actually pretty
simple it actually is a kind of a small
backpack but it fits a lot of things
this one is really good it has a pocket
that's perfect for passports it has a
pocket here that I put my keys in and
Advil for the nicer alcohol back pocket
for your laptop and I would highly
recommend it if you are a person like me
that likes to have things and dedicated
places and if you don't need a ton of
space for I don't know why you travel
with if you just have small stuff that
you want to carry it 45 battery packs
like that then this is a good choice
tissues I use a brand called tempo
they're German I think and they are very
soft but very strong
I thank Kleenex to be super soft but not
very strong but I'm pretty allergic to a
lot of things that grow in the spring in
the summer so I need tissues with me
always especially if I travel to Europe
it's really bad or if I decide to cry
cuz I'm really sad but also really good
for that I don't know if you can get
them in America it's a mess with you I
have a lifetime supply at home so I will
never run out of tempest my Cologne
I wear Chanel allure balm I've been
using the same Cologne since I was maybe
17 16 7
I'm so used to that I can't smell it
myself anymore
I think whatever in my nose is dead
after using this for so long but people
always say that I smell nice and this is
the reason it's not me at that is that a
thing yeah that's right here in there
but not full ones I guess I could just
do two like normal people do but I guess
I feel really extra when I use this this
is we call it hand banana but it's a
neck pillow I've been using this for a
long time as you guys probably know by
now I have a very specific taste and I
stick to the things I like it has the
option to basically straighten it out
and you can put it you know as a pillow
for your lower back and then my dear
hand banana has the feature tightening
it and my secret travel away is making
this as tight as possible it gets
relatively hard window-seat is something
that's essential but I couldn't bring it
with me so just bear that in mind and
then this set leans to the window
and it's magic once I was skydiving I
had a window seat and on the way up I
was just kind of like till I realized I
have to jump out of a plane
my next essential is a laptop charger I
personally use the new MacBook and they
only have used PC so this was a
Kickstarter that I found this side has
the USB see that you put into your phone
but you also have the three used beasts
that Apple stole from your life you get
them back I use the same charger for
both my iPhone and my laptop and if you
need to plug in the USB key to for music
or whatever you can also use this and
it's the exact same size as your regular
Apple charger but you can also hide the
cable in here it's got like a little
pocket so it actually becomes even
smaller and you can detach this so it
just becomes a little little cube like I
I am too because I bought things that I
never received so if you see this and
you've been one of those send it to me
[Music]